hello good morning everyone and welcome
to another edition of alexa and friends
uh as we do here most weeks we have a
fantastic guest joining us
uh rui sarakaya and in just a moment
i'll bring him on but i wanted to make
sure that everybody knew we're using a
slightly different tool today so if
you're used to the
the nice star field that we see in the
background and all the kind of space
looking things
uh we don't have that today but what we
do have is a very powerful tool
that allows us to bring guests in just
like this and with that
rui's here on the screen thank you so
much for being here today
thank you jeff uh excited to be here uh
thanks
for inviting me uh yeah
i'm glad we could make this happen so
let me uh let me zoom out just a little
bit
and i'm gonna do one more thing since
we're trying all this at the same time
i like the zooming in better
jeff i don't hear you now are you muted
yes i am unmuted i apologize my uh i had
a my other computer was going
crazy uh making a bunch of noise so good
morning thank you for being here
um one of the things that i really like
to do when we start these interviews
is to ask a couple of silly questions
right here at the beginning so
if you don't mind we're going to get
right into that i want to get to know
you i want to get to know the person
um and so the first question that i
really like to ask is
if you could pick any one super power
now again a lot of people think i want
to be superman or wonder woman or
whatever
you only have to pick one power superman
one room they have lots of individual
powers
put together to make the awesome
superhero uh what would your one
superpower be if you could pick one
yeah that's a tough one i was thinking
before the interview if i survive the
first 10 minutes of the interview i will
be fine
i uh i think
you may not think that this is a
superpower but i like to
live healthy until a late age
you know i can pick a number uh 90 100
but live healthy without any health
problems that would be the super power
i would do you have to choose to be
healthy or can you have like pizza and
donuts and all the awful things but you
still stay healthy
yeah including death
perfect i i like that i was thinking
the other day about an interesting
superpower i don't know if it's good or
bad
but it would be knowing when you'll die
like you get to know that the whole time
i wouldn't like to know that i i feel
like it would be bad to know but it
would be a really interesting thing to
have especially if it was like 95 years
old
that means i can do anything right now i
can jump out of airplanes i can do
whatever i want
i'm not going to die until that day i
think that would be
i think that would be pretty interesting
that thinking um change the as the time
come close
yeah yeah yeah that's true uh so you
know so you want to be able to stay
healthy
regardless of your behavior uh i like
that
i think that's a good one that's it's
almost like self-healing a little bit um
but
i think that's a good one um all right
so
here's another fun one you uh you're in
front of a very plain wall so i don't
have a good view of your office or your
home where you're probably staying but
i'm always interested to know this about
people
if you had to pick one between your
office your bedroom and your car
which one is the messiest
my car your car are you like
throw throw stuff in the passenger seat
floor or
yeah a little bit i mean it's not i
don't hold uh to be clear
uh uh uh office and bedroom you know
i have uh my five wife and uh
family and they put some pressure just
you know
put this in place and you know clean
this up uh so i have to go
by with that uh inc it's mine uh so
i have more control got it i think
that's probably true for me too my
office is not in perfect condition
but my car is also quite quite a thing
sometimes
uh though i do try to keep it clean
because i take my family places and they
they want to have places to sit
you know ride in the car too uh all
right so last one this is my favorite
question and i uh
i think you've probably heard this
before if you've watched any of these
other episodes
um i want you to imagine for a moment
just you know picture yourself
you're walking through a busy city and
the place you need to get is down an
alleyway
and so you make a turn you're like i'm
just going to cut through this alley
this will be easy
and you get about halfway through the
alley and at the other end the direction
you're heading
a giant horse-sized duck appears
and that giant duck looks aggressive
right it looks angry like um
i don't know that i want to go that way
so you turn around and you go the other
direction only to be confronted
by 100 duck-sized horses
so a bunch of tiny tiny horses at the
other end they also don't look very
happy with you
you need to get out of this alley some
way probably by fighting
which direction do you choose to go
yeah this is a tough one i would ask
some clarifying questions though before
okay okay let's get into it the first
one was you sort of answered so they're
there to get me
i suppose right okay uh is that anything
in the hallway
uh like chairs
you might have access to a dirty puddle
on the ground that's about it
dirty puddle nothing
and it is a horse a
dark sized horses are they uh behaving
in a coordinated way
or are they randomly moving around i
mean
i have to assume that they are out to
get you so as coordinated as that would
be
okay uh then in that case i would i
would go with the
um horse-sized duck the one giant duck
one giant that's my that's my pick too i
think that's the right choice
um i like that uh
and i like that you've given it some
thought too um this is something that's
very important to me for people that
really think deeply about duckside
horses and horse-sized ducks so
uh thank you for for entertaining uh not
only our audience but me with uh with
your answers
uh all right so let's get into why we're
really here
which is to get to know you and to
understand some of the things that
you're working on
so where i like to start these
interviews is to understand
your story right you've you've been in
meetings or you've talked with people
and they're like how did you how did you
get here what like what was the path you
took to get to this job
uh and i tell a long story about how i
started in psychology and then i got out
of school and made no money so
i got into software right at the right
time and here we are 25 years later
i would love to hear kind of your origin
story how did you
how did you get here where you are today
yeah that's a good one
so i am from turkey so i grew up in
turkey
and uh i went to college in turkey too i
did my undergrad
how did i end up here in in a
conversation leia is an interesting
story it's random in some ways but you
know these things sort of shape up your
life
i was in my senior year this is around
1994.
and you know in senior year you need to
take a project uh you know a senior year
project and you complete the project so
i remember uh i
went to downtown my university was in
the outskirts of ankara
and there were these shuttles that you
need to take to go to downtown i don't
know why we went to downtown but we went
to downtown
and this is the day where the professors
actually put up the projects the
potential projects for you to come and
pick one
and we went to the uh downtown with my
buddies and then
uh there the shuttle to universities
every hour
and if you miss the shuttle you need to
wait an hour to get the next one
of course there's a you know poor
student you don't have the money to get
a car
at a cab to go to the university it was
expensive
so we missed the shuttle and you know
the
professors would put up the projects at
1 1 pm
and we missed the shuttle at
12 p.m so we had to wait for the next
one
uh by the time we arrived all the you
know
interesting projects were gone and also
the professors you know we
prefer professors who are uh nice uh
nice in the sense that you know easy
going and you know they won't give you a
hard time
right and there was one uh professor
maybe he's watching us uh professor
uh over morgan he's a cool cool
professor he's a good one
and i wanted to take a project from him
uh and he had two projects so i went to
his door
and uh one of them was mechanical snake
and the other one was uh it's uh
isolated digit recognition using neural
networks
yeah like digit zero two you know zero
one two zero to nine
and this is early nineteen uh mid
nineties and
so i was debating with my buddy you know
which one is uh interesting like
very scientific debate you know
mechanical snake seems very spooky
away from it yeah okay you know i went
with the
isolated digit recognition using neural
net so
i didn't remember anything in the
evening i came to the dorm room
debating with my friends oh what is your
project and i'm go
i go you know i didn't remember anything
but i knew that this was
i will say one to the computer and it
will understand it i will say
two it's the computer it will understand
it that was that was cool the idea was
cool
yeah and i stuck with it so i took this
project and then you know i applied to
grad school here
and you know senior project is something
an asset that they can
uh you know uh make a point of and i got
accepted to clemson university masters
program then i
moved to duke university working on
speech recognition national language
understanding
from that i went to ibm ibm watson
research center
this is early 2000 that's one of the
best places back then you know you
didn't have
amazon is just taking off you know many
companies
facebook wasn't around google is maybe
starting
so bell labs and ibm were the place to
be at that time
so i went to ibm watson research center
i stayed there for about 10 years
i did research just pure research wrote
a lot of papers patents
everything then i realized that you know
i can stay here for another 20 years and
retire
but i didn't want to do that i also
realized that
you know i wanted to impact the
customers lives
versus you know writing the papers so
at that time microsoft reached out to me
that you know we're building a
conversation the ai team
at microsoft and you want to come and
join us so i took that
i joined uh microsoft and i stayed there
five years and i worked on
building cortana so that was a good
experience too
and at the same time while working on
cortana uh
my uh colleague rohit prasad who is my
manager right now
i know rohit from my ibm days we he was
at vbn and we were working on
joint tarpa programs like speech to
speech translation projects i know rohit
for
you know 20 years maybe by now and
he was pinging me you know would you
consider alexa we are doing great things
here
so uh you know i jumped uh that okay
you know that let's talk and then great
and
alexa was super exciting to me it came
out of nowhere
uh you know just looking back actually
uh in many ways google microsoft they
had this
uh nlp a natural language understanding
national language processing machine
learning
muscle way ahead but amazon came out of
nowhere and it just surprised everyone
and i wanted to be part of that journey
and i joined
alexa in 2016 and it's been four years
and
three months now uh building cool things
for our customers it's that's
interesting you and i have had a similar
path
um not i i haven't known rohit for 20
years but
the the idea that you saw alexa and the
appeal that it had
um and came here about i i came here
four years and three months ago as well
so
uh that that's very very cool and i i
have a very
similar similar story uh related to
microsoft so i was working at microsoft
before i came here
and in between i did about a year at a
startup and
one of the things that i had done we
every summer at microsoft they had a um
idea hackathon contest kind of thing
where you
there was one week in the summer that
you could dedicate to just working on
whatever you wanted to to come up with
an idea to invent something
and me and two of my friends decided to
sit down and we had just seen cortana
and we thought it was really neat this
was in
mid 2014 uh and i said we said man this
would be really cool and i have this
amazing video we made a trailer
of us building a device that was about
the size of an echo dot that just
plugged into a wall
uh that you could just talk to and you
could ask it like do i need more milk
and
what time is it and play my favorite
song right it was we in our heads we had
invented alexa
the the the echo device um
using cortana as the back end and when
we pitched it
um nobody at microsoft thought it was
very interesting
so so i had that sitting in the back of
my head it was something that i thought
was really exciting and interesting
and i went and worked at a startup in
healthcare and did that for a little
while and then
um alexa came out and i was like you've
got to be kidding me i
this was the thing i wanted to do and so
i reached out to some people that i knew
and they were like yes we think you
would be a good fit on
amazon team and here i am so that's
that's great to hear
um what a fun background you've had uh
clemson and duke those are two fantastic
schools
yeah they're good schools very good yeah
uh all right so so that's your origin
story so that got you here to amazon can
you tell us a little bit about what your
role is here what your
what your responsibilities are at amazon
yeah i am
in uh alexa ai
organization uh under alexa ai
organization
uh i built and i'm leading a team called
intelligent decisions
and uh i'm the director of director of
applied science
um in ai so that is the role
uh if you want to get into like what we
do in the team i can get into that too
or maybe that will come up later
sure sure i think that's that's a good
start
so you mentioned ibm and microsoft
before amazon um
how do you feel like those experiences
prepared you for what you're doing here
yeah well uh all
along i have been i was thinking the
other day
is that anything that i haven't done
with you know speech
language and ai there wasn't anything i
touched
everything you know from low-level
signal processing like you know speech
enhancement speaker recognition
speech recognition uh natural language
understanding machine translation speech
translation dialogue management
like everything uh so that was a
privilege
uh the learnings though you know the ibm
i
it was more on research core research
so that was rewarding in many ways just
you know understanding the fundamental
research and
moving the needle but always you know
what i have
here is oh okay this is going to you
know open up new possibilities new
products
and it's going to change the lives like
the paper that you
you know wrote that seemed like okay
everything is going to open up new
possibilities
why i don't do that as a foster just
writing and something and someone else
is going to pick up and you know make an
impact on
people's uh lives and that made me to
think okay i like to move to product
team this is actually that's
when i joined microsoft i didn't
join research team i joined the product
team to build the product
and i am a firm believer of actually
science
in product and not science
separate especially in our area because
customer
problems are super interesting it
actually the problems are novel
and we come up with these interesting
ideas
uh to problems that we didn't know
before
that's what makes it exciting that you
know you solve these tough problems at
the same time
you actually see the impact of your
product
uh with the end customers you know how
their lives are getting better how
they're using your product
learning from that that's super
rewarding yeah i i can only imagine so
have you see i mean you've you've been
through it um certainly over time and
across companies
have you seen how how have you seen the
field of like
natural language understanding and
conversational how has that evolved
over the time that you've been here yeah
this is interesting even
let me go back to what i just said i was
working on
as i said in mid-90s isolated digit
recognition
zero like darling of course
at that point it was a little further
ahead like there was continuous
speech recognition starting to take off
but very limited vocabulary like you
know maybe 5 000 words
vocabulary it didn't cover everything
and the accuracy wasn't
you know great uh speech recognition and
ai
has been always you know you know uh
one day uh it will blossom one day it
will take
take off uh but that was an elusive
thing though
it never came and this has been around
for
you know since uh 70s uh you know one
day speech recognition natural language
computers will be able to understand
hear you
understand you and reason uh about what
you just said
uh it just kept moving out uh
into the future um so i think there were
a few things that happened uh that now
it is a reality
uh one one was this uh
what i call the sensors and
compute the sensors got cheaper
and pervasive uh the machines could
detect
you know any changes in the environment
and even then you take your
take you know look at your phone there
are tens of sensors there
you know uh measuring uh the
you know touch light uh and any movement
you know physical
uh you know uh moment um
the that that was one thing the compete
got cheaper uh and powerful
uh the you know again this phone you
know
going back 10 15 years ago you know you
can't imagine that you will fit
everything into the score
you know computer that you're holding in
your hand sure
and uh with that the last piece was
the deep learning uh that made a
tremendous impact it started in you know
2010
and it's ongoing until today
this fast compute cheaper compute
improved machine learning algorithms
and they as i said the sensors uh that
feeding information to this machine
learning systems
uh just it was the right combination
uh you know that
made it possible uh you know systems
like alexa
today got it um i have a question from
the audience and i'm gonna i'm gonna
phrase it a little differently
um but i'm just curious as you look at
the challenges um
have you primarily worked on english or
i guess the real question is
when we look at spoken languages which
ones do you find
the most challenging yeah i i
i've worked on many languages if i
counted
you know all european languages
asian languages chinese japanese korean
um even hindi uh i
they this is actually this is what we
are doing with alexa today
when we are launching uh features
we tend to you know if there's invention
risk high invention risk
we tend to you know launch it in us but
quickly we follow with other locals uh
you know
uh right now alexa is in you know 15
locals
and we like to expand it so yeah i do
have
exposure to other languages and
complexities as well
if getting it you know which languages
are easy which languages are difficult
the english is easier because we know a
lot more about it we have more resources
about it we built
tools uh for it uh there are languages
that are
difficult because of their morphological
structures uh
uh you know like german is a difficult
language there's compounding
you know uh turkish is a different
language it's a gluten native language
literally you can have one word uh
corresponding the ten words
in english one word and that's the
entire sentence
you have different challenges for asian
languages like
you know they don't have pronouns for
example in japanese
arabic they don't have the vowels uh in
the language
uh it's all consonants and you need to
infer vowel from the context
they do have different challenges and
they present new problems to machine
learning
oh for sure i can only imagine i i've
certainly heard of languages where if
if you put the emphasis on the wrong
syllable in a word
it's a completely different meaning and
i can only imagine the challenges those
percent
as well so okay let's let's move on
thank you for that um
so let's talk a little bit about uh ieee
the institute of electrical and
electronics engineers
um i heard recently you were named an
ieee fellow
um and i'd love to know you know kind of
can first of all congratulations on that
i know that um they're described as the
world's largest technical professional
organization dedicated to advancing
technology
for the benefit of humanity which i'm
all about like how how can we use
technology to help humans
live their lives better i think that's
fantastic what's your involvement in
that organization
yeah thank you by the way uh
yeah i am um honored and
and humbled uh by that decision um
my involvement uh with ieee going
it goes back to my undergrad years i
studied electrical engineering
electrical and computer engineering
and uh in my first year
i became an ieee member student member
so i am uh like 25
about 25 years i am an ieee member
student member
member senior member and and fellow now
uh happily
uh uh so i uh
got involved actually the involvement uh
uh
uh gets bigger uh once you have your phd
student you know the right triply
activities i got involved with that you
know bringing speakers and
making sure that the students careers
are improving they know
you know what's the state of the art the
you know magazines
that they're following once i got into
grad
school they were doing my phd then i got
involved with
like the conferences paper reviews uh
right
and uh after that uh i
started to be part of the community more
like i attended many conferences i
uh chaired sessions as you're you know
maturing in the area and making uh
contributions and impact
uh i started to give you know keynotes
and different conferences
um uh so i've been and i
i changed conferences as well uh you
know there were a few conferences that i
chaired like organizational
uh these conferences yeah i was part of
the editorial board for
uh some ieee journals uh
so i'm i'm closely involved with it
activities uh
up until today i even though i'm you
know super busy
with uh alexa i still uh
review uh papers for ieee conferences
that also helps me to
uh you know stay close to the ground
yeah what's happening in the area
what's happening exactly to this day
there are a couple conferences in the
conferences i i'm a reviewer
very good very very cool
um all right so let's let's talk about
your team and what you guys are doing
here at amazon so you lead a team at
alexa ai called intelligent decisions
i would love to know more about what
that organization works on uh
and some of the science behind the work
that sounds super exciting
yeah okay
the as the name implies it is about
making intelligent decisions uh that
wasn't
uh you know a coincidence it was
actually we were deliberate when we were
picking that name
tom picked that name for us and we are
living
you know trying to live up to that name
so we have um
what we are doing for customers let me
start with that uh
you know uh
when you look at alexa you know the
customers speak to alexa
and we uh you know first we do the
speech recognition right but what is it
that the customer is speaking to alexa
and we understand the you know the
customer's intent
right and then uh
this is where intelligent decisions come
into play okay i understood what the
customer is saying
now i need to you know find the right
um application uh or skill as we call it
uh to dispatch this request to
you know what is the right skill that
should answer this request like they
give give an example you know um
alexa play frozen
uh right uh alexa wake up jeffree
alexa stop i should be careful
no i'm muted now i have a whole library
of devices here
they're all red uh except that one and i
heard you say alexa and i was like oh no
yeah we're good now yeah so you know
what is the right application
uh that should answer this request you
know is it the
music application is it the you know
video is it
you know podcast is it weather
is it smart home so we determine uh
where to route this request given the
context though
you know we will get into those
questions later on
i hope it is a complex problem uh
because
uh you know alexa is uh showing up in
ever increasing endpoints and ever
increasing context
alexa is before it was in our home right
in our you know kitchen
now alexa is in the car uh you know
you're reading the news today i read the
news with gm
uh you know it's in the car alexa is in
the hotel room
right now and alexa is getting
integrated with
uh our partners and different endpoints
uh you know through services like alexa
voice services
alexa skills kit the customers are
integrating alexa
to their devices and building skills as
well
and that's increasing the context under
which alexa needs to
operate and that complexity is what we
are solving
uh with intelligent decisions this is
part of this is actually part of the
intelligent decision that is the other
part
with this ever increasing complexity
they we need to
be able to learn uh you know the iai
part
we are inventing new methods to learn
from the customer interactions customer
feedback
as opposed to someone sitting down and
you know
telling us what alexa should do it's not
going to scale
in this you know complex with this
complexity of increasing context
and and the metrics also how do we know
that actually we are making the right
decisions
uh and the customers is happy with our
decision that's another area that this
team is driving
you know inventing the metrics and to
measure the cx
uh customer experience the last part is
new ideas that we
are going to touch on that uh you know
the contextual understanding
and multi-skill experiences that we
want to understand the customer we want
to understand their latent goals
we want to bring these experiences in a
seamless way
because we do have you know over 120 000
skills you don't know all these skills
then customers you know especially
in a voice forward introduction mode
like alexa
you wouldn't know what are those things
so we are you know making the customers
aware at the right time
uh when they're interacting with alexa
so that oh
there are these other things that
actually can help you to solve your
problem
but let me pause here for a second they
have we have other uh
you know features uh other systems but
i don't want to you know cover all of
them but those are the key ones
sure sure so we'll let's get into that a
little bit though so your team recently
had a
launch for alexa new capabilities um
but before we get to that can you give
me an overview of some of the
advancements that have come out of your
group
um that have gotten us to where we are
today yeah
one is uh you know the routing is one uh
that
we announced uh this in alexa live
back in july uh that the you know
developers
come and uh we uh
uh launched what we call the name free
uh interaction uh kit where the uh
third party skill developers they can
come and they can you know
onboard to nfi toolkit and that will
give them opportunity to
receive traffic from alexa in a natural
way
uh you know if you look at the third
party skill interactions
they primarily you know you need to know
the skill name uh you know alexa
ask you know uh
pick a skill animal sounds you know uh
to make uh a whale sound like it's
you know that very cognitive load is
super high the customers don't remember
the skill name they don't remember what
to say
so instead of doing that we what we're
solving is you know
you know how does uh an elephant sound
like
just say it in natural language we will
find the right skill for you
and we will you know get the answer from
the skill then the skill is going to you
know give you the
whale sound directly in one go just
removing that friction from the
customer's interaction
this is uh one the other one is
well this this is self learning uh we
have an internal program name but i'm
not
i'm not going to get into it uh but let
me explain that with an example
uh going back i don't know maybe a year
ago when
a customer you know speaks to alexa
alexa play abcds alexa didn't know
what abcds is and then you know we give
sorry you know i don't know that or
sorry i don't have an answer for that
but then uh with self-learning observing
the customers and their interactions
this is
you know all the customers some
customers
they said alexa play abcds and alexa
didn't do the right thing and they
followed up with
they reformulated their request and
followed up with alexa played alphabet
song
and alexa played the alphabet song
because the proper name for that song is
the alphabet song
but customers you know think the abcds
should work
but we learn without any manual
annotation from the customer
introductions that actually the right
phrasing of this
alexa play abcds is play the alphabet
song so
we do it on the fly we do this mapping
uh and the formulation on the fly
and the customers when they say abcds
alexa plays alphabet song
it is seamless they don't actually
notice it that's the beauty of it
it happens under the hood right no but
that's so clever because you know there
are times where it's going to fail it's
just not going to know the answer
um so we're we're training our users our
customers in some ways
to keep going like try again that will
help us learn
in the future how to solve these
problems not only for you but for other
people
it's it's almost like we're we're
teaching the customers how to teach
alexa
yes that's great exactly exactly uh
absolutely there is actually the that's
the key part uh
i think one of the key driving force for
intelligent decisions is
learning from the customers either
implicitly as in this example
or explicitly we are also engaging with
customers when we are not sure
you know you you may have run into this
uh feature yourself i
i do run into it from time to time you
know uh
when i say alexa set up a timer for
uh you know 15 minutes alex you know
sometimes i'm walking away from the
device
or sometimes it's noisy alexa confuses
15 and 50.
then alexa you know engages with me you
know
is it 15 or 50. i say 50 then it sets
the
versus you know it sets the wrong long
uh uh
timer then i need to go back and cancel
it and you know it's
natural when we are interacting with
human beings this is what we do too
you know if i didn't hear you well i
clarify with you before i you know take
an action
so it's we are making it more natural i
love it
i love it so um i i work with a lot of
skill developers i'm sure some of them
are watching here today
um what are the developer benefits of
some of these capabilities i know you
mentioned name free skill and vacation i
know that's near and dear to a lot of
developers hearts because it gives them
the access to customers that don't know
their skill exists they don't know that
the name
is even there but people are using their
skill because they ask for something
that relates to what's inside their
skill
what other examples of that do you have
so the
benefit to skill developers let's go
back to actually the customer problems
here
and then what does that mean for the
skill developers
the customer problems is the skill
developers are building their skills
the however the customers do not know
the selection
do not know all the available skills uh
in alexa store that they can interact
with as i said there is
over 120 000 skills there's no way you
know and for any
human being to go and remember all of
these right and
because of this discoverability issue
the skill developers uh may not
get traffic as much traffic as they
would like
to their skill right uh with the
nfi uh name free introduction um
container that we launched uh we are
allowing to uh skill developers to come
and specify these
top level you know utterances and
intents that they should be
they would be handling they're letting
that us letting us know about that
with that uh now the customers are
interacting with alexa we are
see naturally and seamlessly finding the
right uh
skills and that is increasing the
traffic and engagement for their skills
so what is in it for them is
more traffic more engagement uh because
of
uh you know uh natural interactions and
uh routing the system that we have
and they when they see increased traffic
they actually go back and improve their
cx
their skills quality that in turn leads
to
more customer engagement so that sort of
turns the flywheel
yeah that we like to turn yeah no i i
think that's a
great example of a flywheel right the
the
the system decides to funnel more more
requests to that skill
which in turn incentivize developer to
make their skill better and to have more
features
which in turn you know pushes the cycle
further so i think that's great
um so i've had the luxury of being able
to interview a bunch of folks from the
alexa science team over the past few
weeks past few months honestly
and there's all of these launches and
science behind how we're making alexa
more conversational more natural
i know your team was the was kind of the
engine behind the latest announcement
related to how we infer customers goals
um
can you give us an overview of that
announcement and what went into that
yeah that's also one of the exciting
programs uh that we have
it's it's a it's a new feature we have
different features and programs and are
in different levels of maturity this is
actually at the beginning phase
but we are super encouraged with the
results that we are seeing so far
so this feature is um uh what we call
uh the multi-skill experiences
what i mean by that is you know we
looking at the customer's interactions
let me explain this with an example
you know the customer comes and asks a
question to alexa
alexa how long does it take to steep
tea right there the customers
needs this piece of information to do
the next thing
that they have in mind they have a
latent goal the latent goal
is actually there's tipping t they want
to set a timer
right and uh we automatically
infer the customer's latent call and
when customers
ask you know how long does it take to
steep tea
then we follow approactively engage with
the customer and
uh you know ask um do you want me to set
up a timer if
alexa says you know it takes five
minutes to set a steep t
then the follow up is do you want me to
set a timer for that
and uh if the customer says yes we carry
over that five minutes
and the timer is set for five minutes
all we need is the customer say yes
so it again removes the friction it
naturally carries the contacts from one
uh skill to next skill and
to complete the customer's latent goal
there are other use cases where again
going back to addressing the discovery
problem
uh you know um like
what is the loudest animal uh in the
world this is a question
and we say you know blue whale is the
loudest animal
uh in the world and you know we follow
up
do you want to hear how blue sound a
blue whale sounds like
well they didn't know that there is
actually like they can you know make
sounds
or animals so there's sort of you know
addressing the skill discovery too then
yeah yeah i like to hear that then we
play the blue sound there are other
utility
uh more high utility examples even
though we are not you know
traveling that much nowadays and i hope
that will change at some point
uh you know alexa how is the traffic
this uh you know
uh ctac airport right um
uh well the customers latent goal could
be you know
uh to go to airport to get a uber or to
check the flight status
we follow up with the customer you know
do you want to get an
uber uh to ctac or do you want to check
the flight status or do you want to know
the
you know wait times at the airport right
customers may not know that there are
this fun there's this functionality
that alexa supports yeah so
man it feels like there's a there's a
bit of a balancing act though like
between
being proactive and offering them these
kind of suggestions
versus also kind of like not being too
intrusive
um how do you how do you manage those
two how do i not be too intrusive but
make sure i give you the cool stuff that
you want to know about
excellent question so uh you know the
key thing
in everything we do is uh work back from
the customer
right yeah we wanna uh provide utility
and value with the features and
experiences we are launching
we don't want to harm the customer or be
intrusive
or break their flow and
so these experiences we do have a
component that we call triggering
triggering meaning that you know when
should i
a should i engage with the customer in
this context
the context is this specific customer
this specific time this specific place
this specific device uh so i mean
this is an ongoing thing that we don't
wanna you know we wanna
uh we don't wanna create a negative cx
we don't wanna
margin and you know spam the customers
with these uh
you know alexa initiate interaction so
we are keeping a
very high butt on that and we have
metrics
instrumentation and we have also gardeal
that we call
you know for example you are not going
to
send provide the same uh suggestion
uh product uh suggestion to this
customer
say i i don't know the exact number i'm
just you know giving an
as an example say uh not more than twice
in a week
right you don't if you do it every day
then it will become a problem
and we also take into customers affinity
to some of these you know skills and
applications
whether they have used it and they're
you know regularly using it
and there are cases where we want them
to discover these as well
and uh you know all of these contextual
factors are feeding into uh you know
that our triggering is precise when we
are engaging we are looking for a high
conversion rate meaning that customers
are actually accepting
yeah uh so we do have metrics that we
are tracking and we are continuously
improving them
that's that's really interesting so it
really is trying to get to know
a customer on a one-to-one level almost
where you know
this person likes this kind of thing
that they respond at these kind
times of day like that's uh that's
really very
well it's very useful but hopefully it's
very beneficial to the customer too
right they're getting what they want
when they need it
uh which i think is the right approach
that's something i love about amazon
is how customer centric it is to focus
on what are the customer needs if we're
serving their needs if we're making them
happy
uh everything flows from there
absolutely that's fantastic
so so this feature is this is this live
when does this launch
it it is la it is live uh this is live
in en
us uh it's uh this is live
uh for a couple of weeks now i don't
recall the exact date but for a few
weeks
we launched this experience in enus
for a limited set of use cases
to be clear and we do have a large
number of use cases in our pipeline
and we will keep expanding this uh in
the coming years
that's great so i have a i have an
add-on question to this which i
just for my own personal understanding
you mentioned the the steeping tea
example
yeah that's that's one question of
millions potentially that have these
kinds of triggers that could be applied
to them
is there a master list someplace that
someone's compiled of all the questions
or how
how do you identify what questions are
good candidates
yeah again you are asking excellent
questions so in
you know uh that is where the
self-learning machine learning and
self-learning come into play that's the
key pillar that
the key tenant that we apply when we're
looking at the problem
you know work back from the customers
and
bring in self-learning uh from the
get-go
so that it's not an afterthought for
scaling
and the example i gave uh you know
for if the customer is asking uh you
know want to go to the airport right
okay how alex how is the traffic to
airport
this is actually we don't even know the
customer wants to go to airport the
customers are asking that's one
possibility a likely
possibility but there are actually a few
options there right
uh one is uh you know the customer uh
wants to go to the airport and wants to
take a
uber or lyft this is one possibility the
customer actually no they don't want to
take an uber or lift they want to drive
but they want to know
uh you know how is the traffic because
they're going to travel themselves or
they're going to pick up somebody
right and right uh or they're going to
check the flight status they're not
going to
travel to airport now someone is going
to arrive
right so there are all these
possibilities and all these
options for uh customers to
choose from so there is the uh
piece uh that you know we are looking at
the
looking at existing customer behaviors
you know what are these
uh skills what's the core occurrence of
these skills what skills are following
which
what skills we learn this from the data
these promising candidates but then we
bring the customer introduction
and learning from the customer feedback
and the triggering as i described
and quickly determine actually which of
these
paths are promising paths that we need
to follow which of them are
and it's a probabilistic system uh you
know
which which are promising which aren't
promising the system is learning
uh from these interactions
got it um and all of this happens in
milliseconds
i think that's the part to me that is
just it's just mind-blowing to think
about
the way that we're using technology to
solve these problems
in in the time it takes for me to say
something all of these decisions are
being made and fed back to the user as a
response
uh it's remarkable and that's why i'm
here that's why i work on this stuff
is because i just find it so incredibly
compelling to be able to solve hard
problems like this
um all right so taking taking a slight
step back
obviously you're very excited about this
and i think that um this is something
that is
um going to really push the envelope
forward for how people think about using
alexa
but you've been here four years and
three months as i have
what are some of the other things that
you've personally worked on that you're
the most proud of here at amazon
yeah this is the most difficult question
i
i suspect all of my team members are
watching watching
i am not going to pick a favorite child
here
i am proud of all the features that we
worked on
uh and i mean it they actually move the
needle
uh improve the customer experience in a
meaningful way
uh the thing though i don't care as much
about
you know the s if the feature or system
we build is
uh complex or not it's not sometimes the
simple things
actually make a big impact on the
customers
uh i i like those simple things
that are impacting the customers in a
disproportional way
that that's my preference but i you know
we
made impact to customers um in in
along different dimensions i'm proud of
the work that we have done i'm probably
proud of the work the
t you know the team is doing yeah that
that's a it's a great very
politically safe answer i like um all
right so i like to end with uh some
interesting alexa questions one
one that i'll ask you is uh is there an
alexa skill that you find yourself using
regularly
yeah we use i use jeopardy a lot
jeopardy uh
yeah jeopardy is a good one
uh and then another question i have for
you and this only counts for ones that
are plugged in like the ones i have here
behind me
how many alexa devices do you have
actively plugged in in your home
and i have to qualify that question
because i also have
like a stack of boxes these don't count
right because they're yeah
they're just sitting here some people
have extra devices at home that they're
not using
yeah i don't know the exact count but i
can't tell you that it is
close to it's between 15 to 20.
nice that's almost that's probably every
room
every room and you know i have kids of
course
uh uh they all got their alexas as part
of the you know
uh their birthday gifts and now they
want to upgrade
and alexa with the screen we're
negotiating that
uh yeah we have it we have it in every
room uh
i have it in my car as well uh it's i
want alexa to be wherever i am
yeah well i think i think for us people
that are working on the product directly
i think it's important for us to be
using it all the time to understand the
little nuances and
understand when it's being annoying or
when it's being too intrusive
uh but also when it delights you and
like man that was such a great
experience we've really knocked this
part out of the park
uh i i agree with you i have them all
over the place so
um i can't thank you enough for being
here today this was a really interesting
conversation i know i learned a lot
uh there's been a fantastic conversation
in the chat and so i want to thank the
people that were here watching as well
um i know that if you guys want to know
more you can go to alexa.science to read
more about
the blog post and some of the releases
that are coming out uh between
the work that rui's doing and the rest
of his team um so
please check out amazon.science if you'd
like to learn more there i think there's
also some links that have been posted in
the chat
um and i think they just shared a link
related to a blog post about the new
capabilities we just discussed today so
that's that's great
uh is there anything else you'd like to
leave us with before we wrap up here
today rory
this uh thank you uh jeff it's uh
uh super happy that i'm here i enjoyed
our conversation a lot too i think the
this is really the beginning as we call
here at amazon it is day one
and you know alexa is
here to stay and alexa is here and you
will actually see it
more uh you know uh becoming
indispensable and part of your life
there are challenges there too uh you
know to to to solve
let's not uh let's
recognize them as well but it is a
good start uh to a journey and
i think it's going to change the our
everyday life in a in a big way
and i i see this is going to happen in
the next five to 10 years
we have a good start well sign me up the
next five to ten years sound exciting
i'm looking forward to it
uh so again i want to thank everyone for
viewing i want to certainly want to
thank ruey for being here
as our guest today um and we will see
you guys all again very soon in the next
episode of alexa and friends so again
rui thank you so much for being here
today
thank you appreciate it bye everyone bye